okay it's time for some more
relationship advice from the daily wires
resident
relationship guru yours truly uh
actually i'm not a relationship guru at
all but we don't have one here
and they don't exist it's my time to
shine
so um i'm the best you're going to get
right now
we're going to go back now to reddit's
relationship advice forum to see which
lost souls we can guide into the light
and we start here it says my
wife is constantly texting a male
co-worker who resides out of state and
i'm not sure what to do
i've seen the texts and they feel like
they gradually have gotten more flirty
slash
they confide in one another kind of
bummed really
okay so i'm not sure why this is a a a
an i don't know what to do situation
like you confront your wife
immediately right now about it and you
say that she needs to cut off
texting this guy cut off all contact
tell her that she's violated your trust
that she's caused profound harm to your
marriage
that she has a lot of work to do to
rebuild your trust
tell her if she's not willing to do that
to make that effort she needs to let you
know right now so you can start
assessing your options
i mean texting and flirting and
confiding with a man
when you're married is not a small thing
that's that's called cheating that's not
like on the way to cheating that is
actual real life cheating that's that's
an emotional affair
at least if it's not a sign of a
physical affair as well
so no excuse for her behavior um none at
all
don't be understanding don't be
sympathetic you got to be a man
and stand up for yourself all right um
this one says wife might have lost
interest in me and be looking elsewhere
we've been together for five years now
for the last six months we've been
fighting and arguing a lot
it's mostly stopped over the last two to
three weeks but as of this last weekend
she suggested an open relationship
stating that she's read that men are
happier i do not want it
but the more i think about it the more i
feel like she wants it for her
she's always getting hit on even when
i'm right there and i work long hours so
i'm not home a lot
i know if i agreed to this it would be
just for her
i don't want anyone else and even if i
did i'm unattractive and socially
awkward so it's not like i'd get
anywhere
what set me over the edge is that i gave
her my card before work to pay rent
got home and wanted a soda for the store
and as i was looking for in her purse
i found a letter she wrote today it
doesn't say who it's to but it's
obviously not for me and it's signed
love always and then her name i don't
know what to do at this point do i tell
her how i've been feeling
do i confront her about the letter my
god these are depressing
i think i might cry if i had a soul i
would cry
uh but i don't so we're good but anyway
do you
do do you confront her what do you mean
do
yes what else would you do this could
very well be the stupidest person on the
face of the earth what do you mean do
you
what other i mean she literally wrote a
love letter to
another guy
how could you not confront her what
would you what else what's the other
option would you go home
like order a pizza watch masterchef
together pretend everything's fine
is that even a feasible option if i was
in your shoes i couldn't do that that
would be impossible
to do that you you can't be so
cowed so emasculated that you've that
you that you're
that good at hiding your thoughts and
feelings around her
so yes you confront her yes you put your
foot down none of this is okay
none of it is remotely okay and by the
way there's no such thing as an open
marriage
not quite my tempo a marriage by
definition
is closed there's no open marriage
it's like saying that you live in a
house without a roof if it doesn't have
a roof it's not a house
the roof is like sort of the whole point
of the house
that's what we talk about you know
you're living under my roof i need a
roof to say
it's the roof that's the roof is one of
the is one of the main features
of the house and if you don't have that
you don't have a house
um and in a marriage the one of the
primary defining features
is the exclusive exclusivity is the
commitment you make to ano to one
another
so there's no open marriage what there
is is uh it's called adultery
cheating and even if you both agree to
it it's still adultery
all right um next one this is from a
woman it says my husband and i have been
together 10 years and married five this
month
the other night while driving to a
family event the topic of our
anniversary came up and my husband
realized he had rostered himself to work
on the day of our anniversary
no big deal we can go out on the weekend
but this was no surprise to me i can't
remember in the last 10 years
him organizing a gift or trip or any
activity for us
or remembering to take time off of work
for our relationship
unsurprisingly to me he has also not
prepared a gift or anything else
i mentioned to him that i'm okay and i'm
used to it
calmly but maybe not the nicest thing to
say regardless and he got quite
mad at me he started to plan a trip on
the spot to where we were married for
the day
three hour drive each way and i said i
would rather stay the night
he had money concerns about this totally
understandable maybe a little unfounded
i also said something along the lines of
that i wasn't going to get my hopes up
because our plans like this
always fall through somehow i feel like
he got mad at me because i didn't fight
slash was apathetic and i didn't give
him the excuse of
she's being a [ __ ] so i don't need to
get something now anyway
the worst part for me is that once he
had managed to calm down he said the
reason he doesn't give me anything or
plan anything is because he works
and because i don't so i have time to
think about these things
he works a regular nine to five nothing
crazy i only have three days in the year
that are special to me our wedding
anniversary my birthday and christmas
i don't expect him to move heaven and
earth on these days but an
acknowledgement and maybe a cheap
bouquet of flowers would be nice
okay and she wants to know what to do
now
i have to offer full disclosure here and
reveal my conflicts of interest
i myself have made this mistake
recently um i did accidentally book a
speaking
gig on the day of our anniversary the
the last one
which was our ninth and um so we still
went out to celebrate and i got her a
gift and everything
i got her a more expensive gift probably
than i otherwise would have
sort of sort of as a kind of tax penalty
that you got to pay
but um i did miss the anniversary for
work
and by the time i realized the mistake
it was too late to cancel
my commitment and i realized because i
told my wife like just casually i said
oh hey i have to travel to this place on
this date and
i was just telling her and then she
looked at me and she had this look where
i knew i was in trouble but i didn't
know why
and then she said you know that's our
anniversary right you done messed up
and i said uh yeah i mean no
i mean i did i didn't but now i do
so the point is in a way i can empathize
with your poor husband
um though it sounds like he handled this
poorly even more poorly than i did which
makes me feel a little bit better
about myself and um his line that he he
couldn't get you a gift
because he doesn't have time to think of
it like you do because he works
um that i gotta tell you guys that's not
gonna
that's not gonna dig you out of the hole
okay that's not gonna get you out of the
doghouse something like that
um you gotta do better than that so no
question he screwed up
and now he's making excuses and that
only worsens the situation as
excuses always do that said you carry
some blame here too
i have to tell you you're not entirely
innocent
if men are sometimes prone to forgetting
important dates which we are
you're doing the thing that women are
prone to do sometimes
which is saying passive aggressive
things while pretending
not to be angry when in reality you're
seething with anger
i'm okay it's fine i'm used to it anyway
you always do this so it's
whatever it is you always do it so it's
no big deal whatever it's fine
i mean i knew you'd disappoint me it's
like i mean i'm totally used to it so it
doesn't even matter because you always
disappoint me
just stop that stop it get some help
just
cut that out you're obviously mad say
that you're mad
be honest about how you feel explain how
you feel don't expect him to read your
mind tell him how you feel
just present your feelings in an honest
and straightforward way
yeah he's on thin ice getting mad at you
considering he's the one who screwed up
but at the same time
see guys always get mad at the passive
aggressive thing from women
see that always pisses us off more and
you as the woman
you know that and that's why you're
doing it
so you are intentionally reacting in a
way
that is going to heighten the tension
and heighten the anger
while pretending that you're being the
reasonable one
and that makes them even more angry
so cut that out be direct
and uh and and that's it all right um
let's see next one says my girlfriend
confessed that she used to sleep with
married men and doesn't feel bad about
it
unsure of how to handle this you break
up with her next question
population she's a bad person she has
the morals of
like a lizard so just just break up with
her
should i ask my girlfriend to delete
intimate pictures of her and her ex from
her phone
yes actually you're not asking you're
saying
get that crap off your phone right now
or i'm gone you could choose let's see
okay finally this is a good one
this is kind of a story so you've got it
this this is uh this is an epic
adventure of a
of a question says i woke up to a text
from my fiance saying
please call me i'm cleared from work for
two weeks i just have to see this in
person this may be the biggest thing to
ever happen in history
of course i called him expecting him to
say june fools or something like that
but
but no he explained that he's heard on
multiple podcasts and news sites
that the government is going to make a
major announcement about ufos in the
first part of june
he really wanted to see it in person i i
like to think he heard
one of the podcasts he was listening to
his mind i hope so
i just want to know that i'm making that
kind of impact in the world
i asked all the normal questions a
loving fiance should ask like
what in the f have you lost your damn
mind and when i was done with that line
of questioning i got into making sure he
had a place to stay
that he was traveling safe etc if i'm
being honest
he had normal answers to all the
questions and it sounded like this was
something he earnestly felt like
he has to be a part of i know ufos have
been a hobby of his since he was a young
kid
but i never thought he'd disappear from
our bed at 5am
to drive across the country to see
something that very likely might not
happen
just to fill in some info we live in
arizona
wow i'm from arizona
so driving to dc is no small task he
works for a major tech company and just
got assigned to a huge project which
really could propel him to the next
level
if he's successful but his new boss is
also his good friend and i suspect he'll
work from dc as opposed to taking all
two weeks as a vacation time
he has a metric ton of hilton hotel
points that won't cost him to stay
honestly
if it weren't for the space alien part
of this he could have told me he had to
leave last minute for work and i
wouldn't have thought twice about this
except for missing him
i don't plan on breaking up with him
over this but i would love some other
people's thoughts
i can't actually call my mom sister or
friends and say
hey ryan wants to be there when biden
shakes hands with the aliens so he left
in the middle of the night how was your
day
why can't you say that i don't
understand why you can't say that
um i gotta tell you i'm with your fiance
on this one i think he's in the right
what's the problem he's got his head on
straight he's one of the few people who
do
you know he he is treating this issue
with the seriousness it deserves
don't be angry adam don't subject him to
discrimination
just because he's an alien believing
american we're a persecuted marginalized
minority group we deal with enough of
that already
we can't deal with it also from our own
loved ones
the aliens are here we're not alone they
are here now
he's the only guy in the country
reacting the way that he should
he's the sane one why aren't you in dc
waiting for this moment that's what i
call a close encounter so
um may god be with him in his quest
and uh be with you in your coming
marriage
which i'm sure will be eventful if
nothing else
you